en el vídeo anterior cuando usamos la
contabilidad sobre base devengada nos
resultó que teníamos 200 dólares de
ingresos en el segundo mes pero durante
ese mes
vimos que pasamos de tener 100 dólares
en efectivo a beber 100 dólares cómo
podemos reconciliar el hecho de que
aparentemente ganamos 200 dólares como
ingreso pero perdimos 200 dólares en
efectivo y esta reconciliación la vamos
a hacer a través de el estado de flujo
de caja o también flujo de fondos
y vamos a comenzar con nuestra entrada
neta comenzamos con el efectivo del
principio así que nos va a llevar desde
esta cantidad de efectivo hasta esta
otra cantidad aquí vamos a escribir
nuestro efectivo inicial efectivo de
inicio y sabemos que es de 100 dólares y
después viendo la interpretación más
inocente de las cosas las cuentas por
cobrar deberían considerarse como
efectivo o como un tipo de activo por lo
que aquí escribimos nuestros ingresos
netos
durante el periodo
y aquí tomamos lo que sea que esté
reportado en el estado de cuenta de
ingresos en ese periodo por supuesto que
es de 200 dólares y ahora tenemos que
hacer la parte de reconciliación ya que
si esto fuera solamente efectivo
deberíamos tener entonces 300 dólares
donde obviamente no lo tenemos para
hacer esta reconciliación tenemos que
ver los cambios en los diferentes
elementos de la hoja de balance aquí
tenemos un cambio neto en nuestras
cuentas por cobrar tenemos un aumento en
nuestras cuentas por cobrar
aquí lo pongo abreviado para ahorrar
espacio un aumento nos es cuentas por
cobrar y cuando tenemos un aumento en
este tipo de cuentas por cobrar estamos
permitiendo que las personas nos deban
dinero en este caso estamos permitiendo
que alguien nos deba 400 dólares si no
lo hubiéramos permitido tendríamos esto
en efectivo así que estamos posponiendo
un poco el tiempo en el que vamos a
recibir ese efectivo así pues cuando
tenemos un aumento en las cuentas por
cobrar
significa que tenemos aquí unos menos
400 dólares con respecto a nuestro flujo
de efectivo o de caja
y no tenemos otros cambios tampoco
tenemos cuentas por pagar que es el
posponer nuestro pago de dinero efectivo
hacia otra persona pero en este caso no
lo tenemos no tenemos ningún cambio en
nuestros pasivos este es el único ajuste
que hacemos si hacemos esto y en algunas
ocasiones esto se llama el uso de
efectivo esto pueden nombrarse de
diferentes maneras en diferentes
contextos
aquí tenemos nuestro efectivo neto en
operaciones el efectivo de las
operaciones y por aquí podemos ver que
si sumamos todo al menos la parte de las
operaciones sumamos estos 200 menos 400
nos van a quedar nuestros menos 200
dólares si nuestro efectivo inicial es
de 100 tenemos unos menos 200 dólares en
el efectivo de las operaciones por lo
que si comenzamos con 100 dólares y
tenemos menos 200 dólares en las
operaciones nuestro efectivo al final
efectivo al final será de menos 100
dólares esto que acabo de crear aquí
para hacer esta reconciliación entre los
200 dólares positivos de entrada contra
los menos 100 dólares en efectivo esto
es un estado de cuenta de flujo de
efectivo o de flujo de caja y ahora
conocemos los tres principales estados
de cuenta financieros